yes it looks like it looks like usc yeah  it's basically a college campus yeah  it's close football games in pompei must  have been led yeah oh it's been [ __ ]  lit  walking around your balls out and [ __ ]  no real clothes must be [ __ ]  lit got 69. you don't even have to do  anything yeah  he's got stare  she's going to suck her dick in a bath  house [ __ ] leg lit imagine free  balling everywhere you go  it was not lit zachary there was mass  famine  i intermittent fast so  there was mass famine yeah i [ __ ]  love famine dude i'm a feminist and all  that  if i was cool with me i'm a feminist bro  i'm [ __ ] feminine hard like famine  energy like i love it so i'm around  women all the time don't i love that  famine energy